hey friends today I have a really fun
haul this is a bunch of goodies from
Sony now as you guys know Sony has just
recently come out with a new PlayStation
5 it's a slim down version of the
original PS5 now I'm so hyped about this
because we also have some accessories
we've got the pulse explore wireless
earbuds and also this vertical stand and
last but not least we have the
PlayStation portal I have been dying to
try this out this allows you to
wirelessly play games that are installed
currently on your PS5 anywhere in the
house you don't need a TV you can just
play them directly on this handheld so I
am hyped about that I have Spider-Man
all downloaded and ready to go it's
almost the holiday season so I'm so
excited because this is like my time to
play video games and Spider-Man has been
on my to play list since it came out so
I cannot wait to finally get a chance to
play it but first let's unbox and check
out these new
goodies wow this does look so much
smaller okay here is the original
PlayStation like look how beefy this is
in comparison it's also interesting the
slim these two top pieces are actually
more of a reflective kind of surface as
opposed to the mat so this is all matte
this bottom is matte top is
shiny here's the back so the digital
version of the new PS5 is 18% lighter
and the drive version is 24% lighter
you're also going to be getting an
updated solid state drive to 1 TB
instead of the 825 gig SSD that shipped
with the original PS5 I'd love to hear
what you guys think do you prefer this
more glossy look this more slim down
version or do you prefer the original
PS5 either way I love my PS5 and I am
very excited though that they do have a
brand new one just in time for the
holidays now the vertical stand I'm
excited to try this out and see what
this looks
like all right
and there it is wow that actually looks
really good I'm into
it okay new PS5 we're going to open up
your new best friend please
hold
wow this is a nice unboxing
experience so
cool but look how awesome this is it's
super slim the controls feel super
intuitive it just basically feels like a
stretched out PlayStation controller
like look at them they're just just
meant to be I'm so excited to try this
out now I have one last thing to unbox
that's going to go great with
this these are the new pulse explore
earbuds I'm really excited to use these
with the portal because most of the time
when I'm playing something on like a
small screen like this I might be around
other people or I'm on a flight or I'm
traveling or who knows so these are
going to be really great for that also
obsessed with this little charging case
like it looks so
cool oh look how awesome that's so cool
these look so
cool look at all of these accessories so
here's everything that comes in the Box
we've got the earbuds which I just love
this case like look how cool this is and
we've got our little Bluetooth dongle
plus we have some extra ear tips
depending upon what size you need and
just in case you don't have one a USBC
cable so here's all of our new Sony
PlayStation goodies I also posted
something on my social about some of the
new faces that they have for the
original PlayStation 5 and some new
controllers these are the deep Earth
colors they're so pretty and I'm so
obsessed with them and think that's one
of the things that I've really been
loving is all of these super fun
customizable colors that son's been
coming out with for the PlayStation the
V plates are super easy to switch so it
is really fun being able to customize
that when I feel like my PlayStation
needs a new outfit thank you guys so
much for watching and a huge thank you
to PlayStation for sending me these
things to check out I cannot wait to try
out this portal I'm so hyped to see how
it works I just wanted to do a quick
little unboxing here to show you some of
the new goodies and I'd love to hear
from you guys what are you guys playing
right now leave it in the comments below
see you guys in the next video bye